- [Voiceover] The amount
of carbon dioxide, CO2,
in the atmosphere increases rapidly
as we continue to rely on fossil fuels.
The relationship between
the elapsed time, t,
in decades, let me highlight that,
because that's not a typical unit,
but, in decades, since CO2
levels were first measured,
and the total amount of
CO2 in the atmosphere,
so the amount of CO2,
A, of sub decade of (t),
in parts per million, is modeled
by the following function.
So, the amount of CO2 as a function
of how many decades have passed
is going to be this, so t is in decades
in this model right over here.
Complete the following sentence
about the yearly rate of change,
the yearly rate of change in the amount
of CO2 in the atmosphere.
Round your answer to two decimal places.
Every year, the amount of CO2
in the atmosphere
increases by a factor of?
If they said every decade, well,
this would be pretty straightforward.
Every decade, you increase t
by one, and so you're going
to multiply by 1.06 again.
So every decade, you
increase by a factor of 1.06.
But what about every year?
Now, I always find it
helpful to make a bit
of a table, just so we can
really digest things properly.
So I'll say t, and I'll say A of t.
So, when t is equal to zero,
so at the beginning of our study,
well, 1.06 to the zeroth
power is just going to be one,
you have 315 parts per million.
So, what's a year later?
So, a year later is going
to be a tenth of a decade.
Remember, t is in decades.
So a year later is
0.1 of a decade.
So, 0.1 of a decade later,
what is going to be the
amount of carbon we have?
Well, it's going to be 315
times 1.06
to the 0.1 power.
And what is that going to be?
Let's see, if we...
so 1.06 to the,
so to the
0.1 power,
I didn't have to actually
use the parentheses there,
is equal to 1.0058,
I'll just take it with that.
1.0058.
So this is the same thing as 3.5
times 1.0058.
And I should say approximately equal to,
I did a little bit of rounding there.
So, after another year,
so now now we're at
t equals 0.2, we're at
two-tenths of a decade.
Where're we going to be?
We're going to be at 3.5 times 1.06
to the 0.2, which is the same thing
as 3.5
times 1.06
to the 0.1,
and then that raised to the second power.
So we're going to multiply by this 1.06
to the one-tenth power again,
or we're going to multiply
by 1.0058 a second time.
Another way to think about it,
if we wanted to reformulate this model
in terms of years, so per year of t,
it's going to be 315
and now our common ratio
wouldn't be 1.06, it would
be 1.06 to the .1 power,
or 1.0058,
and then we would raise that.
Now t would be in years now.
Here, it is in decades.
And I can say approximately,
since this is rounded a little bit.
And so, every year, the amount of CO2
in the atmosphere
increases by a factor of,
I could say 1.06 to the 0.1
power, but if I'm rounding
my answer to two decimal places,
the, well, we're going to increase
by 1.0058,
in fact, they should, the
increase is by a factor of,
they should, I'm guessing they want more
than two decimal places.
Well, anyway, this is arguably,
this right over here is
five significant digits.
But anyway, I'll leave it there.